The man who brought heroes to life and bad guys to justice,...
...Stan Lee created a comic book universe that was true to its brand name:...
...a marvel.
Born Stanley Martin Lieber in New York City in 1922,...
...Lee entered the comic book world as a teenage assistant in 1939.
An aspiring novelist,...
...Lee helped usher in the Silver Age of comic books in the early 60s,...
...bringing sophistication and mass appeal...
...to a genre once exclusively marketed to children.
I wanted to write about people, not about guys punching each other.
Those people?
Flawed, relatable, lovable characters,...
...Lee's signature breed of superhero.
Remember, with great power comes great responsibility.
It's no fun reading about somebody who's perfect.
You want to read about people that you can identify with...
...because we've all got a problem,...
...and if you can create and write about a character who is flawed,...
...but manages to overcome those flaws, then I think that's pretty good.
In the 70s, Lee relocated to Los Angeles...
...to bring his larger-than-life stories to the big screen,...
...crafting a blockbuster movie and TV franchise that made Lee...
...one of the highest-grossing movie producers of all time.
Lee was a recognizable face too, appearing in discreet cameos...
...his fans eagerly spotted in over 40 movie and television roles.
When he arrived at Comic Cons and red carpets across the country,...
...he was greeted with a hero's welcome.
I still sometimes have trouble believing it...
...because all I was doing was trying to just make a living.
You do these things and then I got to enjoy writing them,...
...so all I was doing was having fun.